Hello, I'm the Nostalgia Critic. I remember it so you don't have to.
Movies go through a lot of changes to get made.
A lot of rewrites, a lot of reshoots, a lot of re-editing,
and often that affects what many people consider the most important part of the movie: the ending.
It's the last thing people see, so
most storytellers agree it's best to go out on top.
But doing so isn't always so easy.
Many movies either rewrite, re-edit or even reshoot their ending to make sure it has a satisfying conclusion.
Meaning, there's other endings
that changed a large outcome of the film.
Sometimes the outcomes are so different, you just gotta say: "What the f*ck?"
Whether for the best or for the worst,
these are the alternate movie endings that have us scratching our heads in total confusion.
And we're gonna look at the top 11 of them here today.
Why top 11?
Because the alternate version
didn't test well with focus groups.
This is the top 11 WTF Alternate Endings.
[music plays]
Nostalgia Critic: Number 11.
The Stanley Kubrick classic had people
rolling in the aisles and questioning their safety.
Not at all like today's politics...
But not many know that this movie
had a very strange alternate ending.
Believe it or not, this classic
Dark Comedy ended with a pie fight.
Yeah, no joke! Or...
Actually, too much of a joke as Kubrick put it.
The scene was shot and edited but the director pulled it out saying it didn't match the tone of the rest of the film.
Apparently, the world still blows up, but before it does
the war room has a battle of their own at the buffet table where things get out of control and they start throwing pies at one other.
The footage is not available to the public,
but there are plenty of pictures on set.
While certainly an entertaining visual,
it just seemed...odd.
And this is coming from a movie where
a guy rides a bomb down to the ground.
In a film where a guy as strange as this could exist,
this still just seemed one step too goofy.
Super weird to say the least, such madness is so bizarre you wouldn't think it'd be possible to even be considered.
"It is not only possible..."
"It is essential."
As the song goes: "We'll meet again"
but not with this scene put in.
Nostalgia Critic: Number 10
Yeah! I'm really going for the hits on this one!
The climax to this film, most people agree,
is one of the highlights of the flick.
Involving space travel, Duck Dodgers, lasers,
lightsabers, Marvin the Martian, Spy Battles,
but the original ending had almost none of that.
And yet was somehow even stranger.
It's a battle in the jungle where a
magical device de-evolves our characters,
resulting in Timothy Dalton becoming a monkey,
Bugs Bunny becoming a cave bunny,
and Tweety Bird becoming a dinosaur
who ends up murdering our villain.
"Uh. Th-Th-The, Th-Th-The...That's all, folks!"
[yelps]
That's kind of grim.
As weird as this got though, it did have one essential line that would have made up for one of the film's biggest problems.
The romance.
"Dad, uh...this is Kate.
Um, we haven't kissed yet or anything."
"Um, we don't really get along and
we have virtually nothing in common."
Kate: "But this could be the one."
That line fixes everything!
The love story in this was done so awkwardly that nobody could tell if it was intentionally bad or not.
This ending not only says that it was intentional
but is making fun of how little chemistry
romantic leads often have in adventure movies.
It suddenly made what was mostly painful to sit through a nice bit of trolling on the audience.
So, how strange.
We have one really great idea that would have
saved one of the biggest problems of the film
in a clumsily handled climax
that's inferior in every other way.
I guess that's just part of the
give or take process of filmmaking.
Proving that sometimes you just gotta say:
"That's all, folks!"
Number nine.
This Die Hard film ends like most Die Hard films do.
Shooting some bad guys, blowing sh*t up and saying a bada** line in the process.
"Yippie-ki-yay motherf***er."
But the original ending had practically none of that.
It was bizarrely quiet, talk-heavy and
even sophisticated.
After Simon gets away with his millions, he tries hiding out only to be discovered by McClane.
You see, he was apparently fired from the NYPD because they thought he was involved with the robberies.
So, he has no trouble putting a
Christmas present on the table,
and yes, that would make this a
Christmas movie like the last two,
and it turns out to be a rocket launcher.
He turns the tables as he plays a game of
"McClane Says."
When Simon gets an answer wrong, he has to fire the launcher, hoping it's pointing in the right direction
seeing how the aim was taken off.
[explosive bang]
"I got a flak jacket."
"Yippie-ki-yay."
It's so different that a Die Hard movie
would end this way.
It's almost completely off
from the rest of the tone.
Some people say "That's what makes it cool!"
"That it's a battle of wits in a totally different setting."
But others say "It's Die Hard!"
"Give us the ***damn explosions!"
I just wanted in because there was a greater chance they would sing "Let it Snow" at the end like the last two.
But I think that ship has sailed for that
with the other sequels anyway.
[tearful] Breaking a Christmas tradition!
Good, bad, hard to say.
Unique from any other Die Hard movie?
Definitely.
[chuckles]
"I'm sorry, that is the wrong f***ing answer."
Number eight.
Okay, there's already some major issues with this movie,
particularly with the ending where Rose dumps
a priceless jewel into the water.
Yeah, f*** all the starving people that money could have saved, it belongs at the bottom of the ocean!
But unlike the original where she performed the act alone,
in the alternate ending, she has people around her frigging congratulating her for it!
After a reasonably funny line delivered
by the late Bill Paxton,
"I don't know what to say to a woman who tries to jump off the Titanic when it's not sinking and then jumps back on when it is."
Okay, that is legitimately well written.
Rose spells out the ***damn message for us and it still makes as little sense as if she didn't say it out loud.
"Only life is priceless. And...making each day count."
But what makes it stranger is she lets Bill Paxton touch the jewel, throws it over and then he laughs joyfully.
[laughter]
Yeah, I'd be laughing like a madman too
if I lost millions of dollars to a crazy windbag.
This makes everyone look like a self-indulgent prick!
At least in the original, it was her doing it in secret.
Here, "Oh, he figured out the meaning of life
and you didn't! Teehee! HAHA!"
"God knows how much money
wasted on this expedition there was!
Your loss, financiers!"
They even throw in a ***damn shooting star,
oh, blow me!
I almost get less fairytale sh*t
from the animated Titanic movies!
Almost.
Some say "Titanic" is a masterpiece,
others say it's corny and clichéd,
but there's no arguing that this
would've pushed everybody over the rails.
"That really sucks, lady!"
Number seven.
So, for the most part,
this movie ends like in the original theatrical cut.
The alien is destroyed, the baby-eyed splooge we're apparently supposed to feel sorry for is destroyed,
and they return to Earth.
In the alternate version though, they land on Earth.
In France for no particular reason.
They pretty much say the same lines about being a stranger to this world when the big TWIST is revealed,
Earth is blowed up!
You maniacs! I...totally don't get the point of this.
Seriously, what did this add?
What does it amount to?
If we're able to send tons of people into space, hell, there's so many people even got pirates up there,
why the hell is Earth just left to rot?
Why was she even concerned about
saving mankind from the alien?
It looks like we did a pretty good job
destroying ourselves anyway!
Was this the prequel to Wall-E?
There's something always kind of nerve-wracking when you find out the action of the previous films
adds up to nothing.
I guess this technically started in Alien 3, but that was just a few characters, this is the friggin Earth!
The friggin Earth! What the hell?!
It's not like a ton else made sense in this movie, but this would have been the icing on the cake of pointlessness.
You think you're a stranger, Ripley?
Well, things don't get much stranger than this.
Number six.
Again, most of the overly complicated plot of this film is kept the same, except for one tiny detail:
Peter's father is still alive.
WHAT?!
Okay, this movie tries to throw every
plot thread it can at you and then suddenly,
after the death of a main character,
you throw this immediately after?
Dude, even comic books need a panel to breathe!
Richard Parker: "I had to die to keep you alive.
I had to disappear to keep you safe."
Yeah, he had to stay hidden to keep
Peter safe apparently.
And only now, NOW is a good time
to come out of hiding.
Yeah, sure, not when his uncle died,
he turned into a half spider,
his girlfriend's father got axed and
the city was in peril twice,
No, no, no, ONLY NOW was the time to reveal that!
Uh, a little late to your own funeral, don't you think?
Literally?
The sad thing is, we actually get some
really good acting from Andrew Garfield.
"What? What? Say it! Say what you wanna say!"
"What do you wanna say?! Where've you been?!"
"You're dead..."
Had the scene been in a better movie or, hell, even just a better time, maybe it could have worked.
But as is, not only does it feel tagged on,
it makes little to no spidey sense.
Number five.
Again, this one is very similar to the original.
It's still a bunch of pilots led by the President of the United States to take down the aliens.
But this time, there's a major change.
When Randy Quaid comes in to save the day, it's not in a fighter jet, it's in his f***ing crop plane!
"It's okay, sir! I got it!"
"Alright, boys, this is it!"
First of all, that's the
stupidest f***ing thing I've ever seen.
Second, who the hell in the military just
let him strap a missile onto his plane?!
Why, sure, you can attach that
to your crappy crop duster,
it's not like we need every single missile available for this mission and you totally look ready for combat.
Take her, she's yours!
In a movie that's already pretty damn corny, this is probably the corniest thing you can muster.
Could this have been the moment that was maybe too corny and might have pushed people over the edge?
Hard to say. It still has Will Smith and landmarks blowing up that seemed to overshadow all the other corny things in it
But one thing's for sure, this ending deserves a hard
"UP YOURS!!!"
Number four.
This ending is so bad, even the director admits it would have ruined the majority of good will the film built up.
Everything goes pretty much the same as the original, with Dante closing up the store after a big fight with Randal.
But the story continues as a guy walks in after he's closed, takes out a gun and f***ing shoots him.
[gunshot bang]
He robs the cash register and Dante dies.
Fitting?
Director, Kevin Smith, admitted
he just didn't know how to end the flick,
And after being recommended that he just cut the scene off a little earlier, he agreed it was a much better choice.
Yeah, no kidding. This has nothing
to do with anything in the rest of the film.
It's not funny, it's not poignant, it's not even really that dramatic, it's just shocking for the sake of being shocking.
Thankfully he caught onto it pretty quick
and it's edited out.
Because of this, "Clerks" remains one of the
most unique and funniest generation movies.
And granted, this probably wouldn't have ruined the film, but it would have been a pointless downer that would have diffused an otherwise hilarious comedy.
What were they thinking? Who knows.
But thank God they knew to cut
the final shot...before the final shot.
[gunshot bang]
Number three.
The third film in the Evil Dead Trilogy
knew how to keep the splatstick coming,
but there was a big difference of opinion between the director and the producer about how the film should end.
Because the movie was marketed more
as its own film and not third in a cult trilogy,
the producers said the ending had to reflect that.
So, in the theatrical version, Ash is the hero
saving the day and getting the woman.
But if you know the Evil Dead movies, you know
it has to end with Ash getting screwed!
So, in the alternate ending, he's given a sleeping
potion which will knock him out for years and years
until he returns to his own time.
But, like a doofus, he screws up and takes too much, resulting in him waking up in a future that's...
Well...similar to France in Alien Resurrection.
"I SLEPT TOO LONG!"
On the one hand, the producers
are kind of right about this ending.
If this was a stand-alone movie,
the theatrical cut would make more sense.
But as a third film in a trilogy,
the other ending makes a lot more sense.
I guess it all depends on what you want to see,
Army of Darkness or Evil Dead 3.
Whatever version you prefer, there's an
ending for each one and they're very different.
So pick whichever groovy version you like best.
Number two.
The original ending to this movie
has practically entered legend.
It's amazing how different it is from the theatrical cut.
Seymore saves his girlfriend from the killer plant, confronts him and ends up destroying both the plant and the evil offspring, saving the world.
That seems about right for a
musical comedy with a dark quirky edge.
But the original goes as dark as it can f***ing go!
Seymore doesn't save his
girlfriend from the plant, she dies!
And when he goes in to confront him, the plant wins, taking Seymore into his vines and eating him alive.
Yeah, so, both our main characters are dead,
killed in bizarrely horrific ways.
But it doesn't stop there.
The plant allows himself to be sold all over the world and when the time is right, they attack!
People are defenseless to stop them, the plant grows bigger and bigger until they completely take over and gobble up mankind.
The end!
This ending is incredibly dark
and remarkably depressing.
On the one hand, yeah, this ending does
kind of make sense for a campy horror film,
but on the other hand, the music was so bouncy and romantic and even...inspiring,
which, I guess you could argue just
makes the original ending more funny,
but really, it's just kind of a big downer!
The theatrical version seemed to
fit the film's identity a lot more.
But...yeah this is one hell of a ballsy ending
and you kind of gotta give it props for that.
It pulled no punches, it went all the way.
Would people have related to it if it was kept in?
Who knows?
But, it's out there for people to see and
you can decide yourself which one is better.
Whether it's the happy ending or the "good God, what the hell" ending, it's an out there experience all the way.
And the number one WTF alternate ending is...
This is declared as one of the biggest
"f*** you" endings if you're aware of the original story.
I'll admit, going into the movie, I didn't know it
or why it was hailed as a classic,
but once I discovered the original ending,
it all made sense.
In the film about an apocalyptic future taken over by mutant people, Will Smith tries to kill/study
these mutants to find a cure.
In the theatrical cut, he sacrifices himself
to kill off them damn mutants,
leaving the side characters to give the cure he discovered to the military to start getting Earth back to normal.
When I saw this, I remember it leaving no impact.
What was the point in watching this?
Why is it considered one of the great stories?
Then, I saw the alternate ending.
It turns out, the mutant trying to get in
was looking to save his girlfriend.
Shocked that there's still humanity in them,
Smith lets them go and realizes he's the bad guy.
The new civilization that inherits the Earth
isn't made up of his kind anymore.
It's a brand new species and he's the Boogey Man, the rare breed that feeds of the majority of everyday life.
He realizes, whether he likes it or not,
he is the monster in the eyes of the new world.
Holy sh*t  is that powerful,
thought-provoking and challenging!
Talk about an eye of the beholder
message in a brilliantly done way.
Even though he lives in this version, it's by far the downer ending that a film about the end of the world deserves.
But nope, the theatrical version takes the entire reason the story was made and completely changes it.
I guess stuff like that has been done before,
I mean, look at the Disney films.
They totally change the meaning
of classic stories around,
but with this one, the tone of the film
matches the original ending.
It's dark, it's gritty, it's heavy, it's dramatic.
It really wants you to feel like you're in a world that has been taken over by a new lifeform and your species is going extinct.
The tone of The Little Mermaid is
completely different from the tone of the original,
so we can buy the changes more.
But with this one, of course, the original ending is better.
Suddenly, everything falls into place.
This isn't just shot like a summer action flick, it's shot like it has something important and timeless to say.
But, the studio disagreed and said "Mankind rocks and we're gonna get our happy ending!"
What a letdown! What a betrayal! What a total castration of what made the story last for so many years!
This is the "not-so-great" ending given to a great story that should have us all saying:
"What the f***?"
Are there any that we missed?
Are there any that you think are worse?
Well, leave them in the comments
below and share the "what-the-f***ery."
I'm the Nostalgia Critic.
I remember it, so you don't have to.
[Nostalgia Critic Theme]